Allo
Sam, j'ai fait une connerie,
il faut que tu rentres à la maison.
Attends, attends, calme toi calme toi,
Qu'est ce qu'il se passe ? Allo...Allo
Jessica !
Qu'est ce qu'il t'arrive ? Qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé ?
J'ai tué quelqu'un je crois
Hein! Quoi!? Tu as tué qui ?
Je ne peux pas parler pour l'instant.
Sam, il faut que tu m'aides à me débarrasser du corps
Il est dans la baignoire
T'es folle ou quoi !!!
Explique moi ce qui s'est passé.
Mais je t'ai dit que je ne pouvais pas parler!
Ok...Bon, je vais appeler les flics.
Je vais aller en prison, je veux pas aller en prison !
Sam.
Je croyais que tu m'aimais.
Je vais t'aider d'accord.
Ça va aller...D'accord ?
Fais moi un câlin.
Ça passe pas !
Si ça passe!
Mais non, ça passe pas !
Regarde ça passe là !
Ah bah oui, c'est pour ça qu'on y arrive si bien!
T'es vraiment chiant!
Ca passe pas je te dis.
Bah effectivement là ça passe.
A 3 d'accord.
1...
2...
Haaaaa, c'est elle! c'est elle!
Bravo, Bravo Bravo Jessica
Samuel vous aime assez pour jeter un corps.
Un cadavre inanimé dans un canal chelou, en pleine nuit.
C'est formidable !
Samuel, un petit commentaire ?
Pas de commentaire ?
C'est relou, très bien.
L'équipe de "Fais moi confiance" est très heureuse,
de vous offrir la somme de 10 000 euros.
Je t'aime mon amour.
C'est le plus beau jour de ma vie.
Est ce que tu veux m'épouser ?
C'est super !
Si vous aussi vous souhaitez piéger votre mec,
pour savoir s'il vous aime vraiment.
Envoyez-nous un SMS au 7 43 43,
ou contactez-nous sur Twitter
avec le hashtag: "Fais moi confiance".
Bonne soirée, et à la semaine prochaine !
"La semaine prochaine dans Fais moi confiance"
"ne manquez pas : Chéri j'ai mangé ton père !"
Chéri j'ai mangé ton père !